The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Hello, and welcome.
So before starting
today, there's
one of those kind of required
announcements for events
coming up.
So even though it seems
like we just did exam 1,
next week is exam 2.
So next Wednesday
evening, 7:30 to 9:30.
Same as before other
than it's Walker.
So don't go to Building 26.
Go to Walker.
OK.
Other than that, the rules
are pretty much the same.
No recitations on
the day of the exam.
Coverage will be up until
the end of this week.
That includes Lecture
12, Recitation 12.
It includes Homework
7, but Homework 7
will be handled the
way Homework 4 was.
So Homework 7
won't be collected.
It won't be graded.
There will be solutions posted.
We'll post previous exams.
You'll be allowed to use two
pages of notes, presumably
the page you used last
time and one more.
Although, we are not going to
check whether it was the page
you used last time.
This is supposed to
be a convenience.
No calculators.
No electronic devices.
Just like last time--
I hope you all found
it to be this way--
the exam was designed
to be done in one hour.
And you have two hours,
so there's not supposed
to be any time pressure.
Review sessions during the
normal open office hours.
And conflicts,
please let me know
so that I can arrange to
get somebody to proctor.
And so that I can get a room.
So for those two
reasons, try to tell me
about conflicts before Friday.
I guess the other
important thing
is remember that the theory
of the exams in this class
is that they ramp up.
The first exam only
counted 10%, with the idea
that that's to let you
get acclimated to things.
You're sort of walking in
the shallow end of the pool
is the idea.
This one will count 15%.
So it's coming up.
The next one will count 20.
And the final one will count 40.
So this one counts slightly
more than the last one,
but you're still kind of in the
not-so-deep end of the pool.
Questions?
Comments?
Questions on the exams?
Good.
So I want to start talking
about a new topic today, which
is really an elaboration
of what we talked about
with frequency response.
But I want to start by
telling you the big picture,
the sort of 30,000-foot view.
We've been focusing
in this class
on multiple representations
for thinking
about how linear systems work.
Differential equations, block
diagrams, impulse responses,
frequency response-- all
kinds of different ways
of thinking about it, with
the idea that if you know all
of them, then you can use the
one that's the easiest to solve
your particular problem.
In almost all of
the cases, we've
tried to find
representations that are
small in conceptual complexity.
So for example,
differential equations.
In principle, differential
equations could be complicated.
In fact, we're only interested
in linear time invariant
differential equations,
which means that they always
have a simple form.
They always look something like
y plus some coefficient times y
dot plus some other
coefficient times y dot.
y double dot plus a whole bunch
of things turns into say b0
x plus b1 x dot plus b2 x dot--
double dot plus a whole bunch
of things.
Point being that although the
differential equations could,
in fact, be arbitrarily
complicated,
we only focus on
the ones that have
a simple representation in terms
of a small number of constants.
There they are-- a1,
a2, a3, b0, b1, b2.
Small number of constants.
So that's the way of
managing the complexity.
There's only a small
number of constants
you need to worry about.
Similarly, when we think about
things like poles and zeros,
the whole point of a pole-zero
diagram is that you reduce.
So say we're doing s-plane.
So say we're doing some
continuous kind of a problem.
We reduced the whole system to
thinking about a small number
of singularities.
Again, we're trying to think
about the system in terms
of a small number of numbers.
We like this one because the
numbers are in some sense more
intuitive or help us to
solve problems better
than perhaps these numbers did.
Both of these representations
are characterized
by a small number of numbers.
But for certain purposes,
one set of numbers
is easier to work with than
another set of numbers.
Last week, we started to think
about frequency responses.
Frequency responses
were really good
for thinking about
systems, like audio.
I did some examples with audio.
Or just other kinds of systems.
It's very good to
think about this kind
of a system as a
frequency response
because there's a certain
frequency at which
a very small input--
you can barely see
my hand moving.
Or, if I weren't shaking,
it wouldn't move so much.
And in fact, the
mass moves a lot.
So that's some unique property
of a particular frequency
that's interesting
for us to know about.
The problem with
frequency responses
is that when we start to think
about a frequency response,
we're now thinking about,
say, the magnitude of a system
function as a function
of omega, which
might be horribly complicated,
and an angle which
might be horribly complicated.
So we've kind of
lost the modularity.
We've kind of lost
the ability to think
about the whole
frequency response
by a handful of numbers.
That's what Bode plots are.
Bode plots are a way of thinking
about the entire frequency
response in terms of
a handful of numbers.
That's why we like it.
We like frequency response
because it's a very good way
to think about certain systems.
Audio because we like to
think about bass differently
from the way we
think about treble.
Mass-spring dashpots because
there are certain frequencies
at which the system goes crazy.
Airplanes because you don't
want it to do that, right?
So there are certain reasons why
frequency responses are good.
And Bode plots are a way of
getting back to this idea
that we can think about a
whole function of frequency
with just a handful of numbers.
That's what we're doing.
OK.
So just to get things
going, remember
where we're coming from.
We think about
frequency responses
by thinking about
eigenfunctions and eigenvalues.
We think about how if your
system is linear and time
invariant, last week we showed
that complex exponentials are
eigenfunctions for
all such systems.
You put in any complex
exponential and what comes out
is a weighted version of the
same complex exponential.
Property of linear time
invariant systems Furthermore,
the eigenvalues are really easy
to find from vector diagrams.
The eigenvalue is the value of
the system function evaluated
at the frequency of the
complex exponential.
Really easy.
And you can calculate that
from a vector diagram, which
capitalizes on the small number
of numbers representation
of the pole-zero plot.
So it's all easy.
We only do easy things.
And then, we're
really interested
in these sinusoidal responses.
So we think about a sinusoid
by using Euler's formula
as the sum of two
complex exponentials.
And that lets us see
that all we need to do
is evaluate the system
function at j omega 0,
j times the frequency
of interest,
the magnitude, and phase.
And that lets us
compute, how much
is the amplification
at that frequency
and how much is the time delay
associated with that frequency?
And so that motivated
us to look at, how
does frequency response
map to pole-zero?
There's a simple mapping,
the vector diagram.
Think about for example, if
you have an isolated zero,
a single zero in your system.
A Single zero here at minus 2.
The magnitude can be determined
by the magnitude of the--
by the length of the
angle that goes from the 0
to the frequency of interest.
Frequencies are on
the j omega axis.
Angle can be found--
this angle can be
computed from the angle
that this vector
makes with the x-axis.
And that always works.
Here it's illustrated
for a single zero.
If you think about the
magnitude and angle
as a function of
frequency, you map out
features that look like so.
As the frequency goes
from 0 to very big,
the arrow goes from
short to very long.
That's manifested by this.
And the angle changes
systematically
from being near 0 to
being up around pi over 2.
OK.
And the same sort of
thing works for a pole,
except now a pole
is in the bottom.
So when it used to get
big, now it gets small.
The angle, which used to go
positive, now goes negative.
But it's the same idea.
And you can compose
more elaborate functions
by thinking about the
individual arrows that
correspond to factors.
That's using the factor
theorem to reduce the system
function, which is always a
polynomial in s, into factors.
OK.
So that was what we
talked about last time
what I want to talk
about today now
is how to reduce the
frequency response, which
looks like a lot of numbers--
one for every frequency-- to
thinking about it in terms
of a small number of numbers.
So the idea is that this
magnitude response is simple
if you look at it the right way.
In particular, it has a simple
value at low frequencies.
If we think about the smallest
frequencies you can have,
that's omega equals 0.
And the smallest
frequencies, the magnitude
response asymptotes becomes
arbitrarily close to the line
that you would get
by substituting omega
equals 0 here.
If omega were 0, then h of
j omega would be minus z1.
The magnitude of minus z1 is z1.
So at very low frequencies,
the response-- so
when you get to
frequencies near 0,
the response asymptotes
to that line.
And if you get to very high
frequencies, then the fact
that you're adding a small
constant to a number that's
already very big, if omega
were large, then that little
constant, z1, wouldn't matter.
So the magnitude becomes very
close to the magnitude of omega
shown by the green dotted line.
So you can think
about the blue line
being some kind of an
interpolation between those two
dash lines, the
low-frequency behavior
to the high-frequency behavior.
And the relation looks
even simpler if you plot it
on a different kind of axis.
If you make it
log-log, then you can
think about frequencies going--
so the log of frequency.
Well, there's some--
if the frequency
were 1, whatever that means.
Or in fact here, it's
important to note
that I'm plotting here
versus a normalized version
of frequency.
I'm normalizing by z1.
What That has the effect that
when omega is the same as z1,
I get the log of 1, which is?
AUDIENCE: 0.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 0, right?
That's a way of shifting
the axis to make
the interesting
stuff happen at 0.
That's all.
So if you scale frequency by
the singularity-- in this case,
a 0--
then the critical frequency
becomes the frequency zero.
We all like 0, right?
So what you can see then
if you plot it this way--
and I also scaled the
magnitude the same way.
So if you realize that
there's a simple asymptote,
you can see very clearly
on this log-log plot
that you get a good
approximation to the function,
which is showed in blue.
That one's calculated exactly.
And you get a good approximation
by the low- and high-frequency
asymptotes.
So instead of thinking about
the whole function of frequency,
what we do is we think
about just the asymptotes.
That's the simplification.
We don't think about this
complicated function.
We only think about what
happens at low frequencies
and high frequencies.
Of course, this was
too simple, right?
This is what happens
with a single zero.
The point is that
a similar thing
happens with a single pole
or when you combine them.
Let's look at the
case of a pole.
Here, the pole idea is a
little bit more complicated.
If you go to very
low frequencies,
think about s being j omega.
The frequency response
lives on the j omega axis.
Always look at s equals
j omega if you're
interested in the
frequency response.
If you think about s
equals j omega, then
if you go to small omega,
this term goes away.
And we're left with,
again, a constant at low
frequency showed
by the red line.
If we look at high
frequencies, now the curve's
a little more funky.
The curve at high
frequencies-- the real answer
is showed by this sort
of bell-shaped curve.
If you plot for different values
of omega where s is j omega,
plot out the magnitude,
you get this sort
of funky, bell-shaped curve.
The point is that--
and the high-frequency
asymptote.
If you just say, what
if j omega were so big
that the p1 wouldn't matter?
Then, you would get 9 over
omega being the asymptote.
So that's this hyperbolic
sort of thing here.
OK.
Well, that's ugly.
But if you go to log-log,
it's very simple.
That's why we like log-log.
If you think about the function
y' equals 1 over omega and plot
that function on
log-log axes, reciprocal
turns into a straight line.
We like straight lines.
They're easy.
So what happens then-- again,
I've normalized things.
I've normalized
frequency by the pole.
That makes the critical
frequency be omega equals pole.
The critical
frequency comes out 1.
The log of 1 is 0.
So the interesting behavior
happens at log equals 0.
Below that frequency, the
frequency response magnitude
is well approximated by the
constant whose log divided
by some funny number
that was put there
for normalization is 0.
And at high frequencies,
it falls off
with a slope of minus 1.
So again, for the
case of the pole,
we get this simple behavior
if we focus on the asymptotes.
OK.
So now, that's kind of the
theory behind everything.
Make sure you're all up
to speed on the theory.
So compare log-log
plots of the frequency
response magnitudes of the
following system functions.
H1, 1 over s plus 1.
Where's the pole?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Minus 1.
And s2, 1 over s plus 10.
Pole is?
Minus 10.
Compare the magnitude.
Compare their
magnitude functions
when plotted on log-log and
answer the following question,
which of these best describes
the transformation between H1
and H2?
You should shift horizontally.
You should shift and
scale horizontally.
You should shift
horizontally and vertically.
You should shift and scale
Or, it's something
completely different.
OK, turn to your neighbor.
Say hi.
Right now, say hi.
And now, figure out
what answer best
classifies that transformation.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK.
So which transformation
do you like the best?
Everybody raise your
hand with the number
of fingers between 1 and 5.
Let me make sure
I know the answer.
I think I know the answer.
OK.
Greater audience participation.
Blame it on your neighbor.
My stupid partner
thought it was--
OK.
It's about 90% correct.
If I plot the magnitude
response for H1 on log-log axes,
what will it look like?
Sketch it in the air.
Sketch it in the air is
like that sort of thing.
Go ahead.
Sketch.
OK.
Maybe that didn't work.
What I want to do is plot the
magnitude of H1 of j omega
log versus the log of omega.
But I only want to think
about the asymptotes.
Where should I draw the
low-frequency asymptote
for that function?
What's the
low-frequency asymptote
for the log magnitude of H1?
What's the low-frequency
asymptote--
forget the log part.
What's the low-frequency
asymptote for H1?
0.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: I'm sorry.
I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: Why is
it not symmetric?
So if you look at the amplitude
of the system function, j
omega, it's symmetric.
But the Bode plots
are not symmetric.
DENNIS FREEMAN: The Bode
plots are unsymmetric.
Why are the Bode plots
unsymmetric and the frequency
response was symmetric?
Somebody--
AUDIENCE: I get why, if you
have a negative frequency.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Negative
frequency, exactly.
Why do we have
negative frequencies?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Because
time runs backwards.
Negative frequency corresponds
to running time backwards,
right?
The argument, it gets bigger
when time gets smaller.
OK.
That's not the reason
we do it, right?
Why do we use
negative frequencies?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Why do we
consider negative frequencies?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: To make it real.
To make what real?
AUDIENCE: A system.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Why do we think
about negative frequencies?
Come on.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: We
want sines and cosines.
It's easy to find
complex exponentials.
We like Euler, right?
We like Euler.
We like that cosine
of omega t can
be written as 1/2 e to
the j omega t plus 1/2
e to the minus j omega t.
That's what we like.
Whoops.
I shouldn't put the
parentheses there.
That's what we like.
We invent the
negative frequencies.
They are completely an
invention of our own.
When we do the Bode
plots, we throw them away.
We know that we can
always figure them out
because it was an
invention of ours,
so we don't need
to write them down.
If we ever needed them,
we could figure them out.
So we don't bother to write
them down on the Bode plot.
What's the low-frequency
asymptote of H1?
If omega 0 goes to 0,
what's the value of H1?
1.
s equals j omega,
omega equals 0.
1.
What's the log of 1?
AUDIENCE: 0.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 0.
So the low-frequency
asymptote for H1 is 0.
What's the high-frequency
asymptote of H1?
If you put a high frequency-
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: We're
thinking about H1 of j omega.
H1 of j omega is 1
over j omega plus 1.
What happens when
you make omega high?
What happens to the magnitude?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1 over omega
for the amplitude, right?
You could say it approaches 0.
That's kind of right, but
we're interested in how
it approaches 0.
On a log plot, 0
is very far away.
So we never think
about being there.
We think about getting there.
So we get there with
a slope of minus 1.
So it's like this.
What's the crossover point?
Omega equals?
What's the omega at
the crossover point?
AUDIENCE: 0.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 0.
AUDIENCE: We're plotting
for negative [INAUDIBLE]..
And I would think
that since we're
taking the absolute
value [INAUDIBLE]
and not having it just be 0.
Because you're talking
about as omega goes to 0,
but not necessarily as
omega goes to negative.
DENNIS FREEMAN: We're
thinking about the limit
as we go towards
0, because we're
plotting on the log of omega.
0, omega equals 0,
is way over there.
Way, way, way off
the blackboard.
So we don't think about that.
We think about how it got there.
And it got there
by being constant.
The trend-- if you start
at the critical frequency
in the middle, the value
becomes closer and closer to 1
as you go to the left.
That's why we say the
asymptote is at log equals 0.
Log of 1 is 0.
The answer goes to 1.
The log of 1 is 0.
Does everybody know
what I'm talking about?
I'm getting a lot
of blank stares.
Then, if you try to
go to a high frequency
and think about
the magnitude, you
can go to a high
enough frequency
where the magnitude
of this doesn't
matter that that's there.
The magnitude never matters
that there's a j there.
So the magnitude goes
like 1 over omega.
If you plot the
function, 1 over omega,
a reciprocal function
on log coordinates,
it turns into slope of minus 1.
So that gives us
this region where
it has a slope of minus 1.
What's the frequency
at which they cross?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
In log scale, it's
only [INAUDIBLE]..
DENNIS FREEMAN: On a log
scale, it's omega equals 0.
On a linear scale,
it's omega equals 1.
So the crossover point
where 1 over omega--
the high-frequency
asymptote is 1 ever omega.
The low-frequency asymptote's 1.
They are equal when 1
over omega equals 1.
Omega equals 1, right?
Log 0.
So they cross at a point
where the log is 0.
Now, how about H2?
What if I plot H2
on top of this?
What's the low-frequency
limit of H2?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1/10.
What's the log of 1/10?
Minus 1.
So now, H2, if I do log
of H2, it's going to--
so the low-frequency
asymptote is 1/10.
It's minus 1 on a log plot.
What's the high-frequency
asymptote for H2?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1/s.
1 over omega.
It's the same.
If you go to a high
enough frequency,
the fact that there
is divide by 10--
the fact that you've added
10 or added 1 doesn't matter.
If omega gets sufficiently
high, the thing you added to it
has no relevance.
You get the same
high-frequency asymptote.
So to transform the asymptotic
view of the magnitude function
from H1 to H2, what should
you do to the curves?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Shift and shift.
No scaling.
That's why we like Bode.
That's why we like log-log.
Every pole looks the same.
Every pole is straight
across and down.
Every zero looks the same,
straight across and up.
There's a critical frequency.
That frequency is the
frequency equal to the position
of the pole or zero.
That's all of the rules.
OK.
That's why we like this.
Does that make sense?
So the answer here
was that we want
to be able to shift
horizontally and vertically.
We don't need to scale.
The shape of the curve is
invariant to the position
of the pole and zero.
That's what we like.
It's an invariant.
We like invariant things.
OK.
Then, if you wanted to construct
a more complicated system,
it's also easy.
If you want to construct
a more complicated system,
you can use the factor theorem
to convert the system function,
which for a system that's built
out of integrators, adders,
and gains.
If you build a
system out of that,
the system function will always
be a ratio of polynomials in s.
We proved that a while back.
You can always
factor such things.
We just found out a
rule for how you think
about the individual factors.
And so all you need
to worry about is
the rule for combination.
If you multiply a bunch
of zeros and divide
by the product of a bunch of
poles, that's pretty easy.
If you take the magnitude--
the magnitude of a product is
the product of the magnitudes--
that's also pretty easy.
Everybody's with me?
And if you take the
log, it's even easier.
The log of a product
is the sum of the logs.
OK.
Sum's easier to multiply.
That's another reason we
like this log-log thing.
So all you need to do is
think about each singularity.
Each one of them can be
represented by this and down
or this and up.
And compose them by adding.
So it's really easy.
So say I had this system
function, a 0 at 0,
a pole at minus 1, and
a pole at minus 10.
Think about the
Bode representation.
Bode's just a word that means
think about the asymptotes.
Think about the Bode
representation for the top.
Well, that grows
linearly with omega.
A function that grows
linearly with omega
has a log that grows
with a slope of 1.
So that's this.
So that's the zero.
That's the contribution to the
magnitude function of the zero.
The contribution to
the magnitude function
of the pole at minus 1 is this.
The pole at minus 10 is this.
All pole's look the same.
So all you need to
do is add them up.
So you add the first
two, you get the--
so backing up.
0.
Pole.
Add them.
In this region, the
sum of a constant
and a straight line sloping up
is a straight line sloping up.
In this region, the sum of
a straight line sloping up
with this sloping down is flat.
So that's why you get that.
Then, we add in
this contribution.
Add a constant to this.
It just shifts it up and down.
Who cares?
That's easy.
The important thing is
that it breaks down.
So the result of summing
that is that it breaks down.
Easy.
So instead of thinking
about a frequency response
as something that's
horribly complicated,
we think about it
as having parts that
came from each pole and zero.
So instead of thinking about
it as a collection of arbitrary
numbers at different
frequencies,
we think about it
as a little part
that comes from the first
pole, another part that
comes from the second
comes from the first zero--
blah, blah, blah.
It's a way of thinking
about it, reducing
the complexity, the
conceptual complexity,
of the frequency response.
So the angles are the same.
If we think about
the low-frequency and
high-frequency behavior of
the angle starting with a 0.
For low frequencies,
the angle is 0.
So that's the dot.
For high frequencies,
as frequency
goes higher and
higher and higher,
the angle stands straighter
and straighter up.
The asymptotic value is?
Pi over 2.
So we have two asymptotes,
0 and pi over 2.
If we plot that on
log-log axes, we
get something slightly
more complicated.
The blue line shows
the calculated value.
The red line shows
a way of thinking
about that from a straight line
approximation point of view.
Very nice construction
is put a straight line
starting one decade--
a factor of 10, minus
1 on a log scale.
Draw a line from minus 1
to plus 1, a straight line.
And you actually get a
very good approximation
to the angle function
over the whole range.
Notice that there are
two critical frequencies
associated with the phase.
There was one critical frequency
associated with magnitude.
What was the crossing point
of the low- and high-frequency
asymptotes?
In phase, we think
about that same thing,
but then we bump
it up and down 1.
So there are two
critical frequencies.
The same critical frequency
we use with the magnitude
plus or minus 1.
The same sort of thing
happens with a pole,
but now it's upside down.
Other than that, it's identical.
Same thing.
Having calculated the phase
for a single pole or zero,
it's easy to think about
how you would generalize
to multiple poles and zeros.
The angle of a product
is the sum of the angles.
Don't need to take
the log this way.
This time, when we're
doing the phase,
we don't need to take the log.
There's a way of
thinking about phase.
Because it's in the
exponent, e to the j angle
by Euler's equation.
There's a way of thinking
about the logs already
in the angle function, right?
The angle was in the
exponent, e to the j omega.
So since the angle is
already up in the e,
it's kind of like an--
it's already a
logarithmic function.
And that shows up here.
The angle of a product
is the sum of the angles.
So same sort of thing happens if
we had a complicated function.
Just think about the angle that
results for each of the poles
and zeros and add them.
The angle associated with
the zero at 0 is pi over 2.
j is the same as e
to the j pi over 2.
e to the j pi over 2.
The angle's pi over 2.
So the angle associated with
this is always pi over 2.
The angle associated
with the pole at minus 1.
Poles in the left-half plane
cause the angle to start out
at 0 and go negative.
So we start out at
0 and go negative.
We find the critical frequency
labeled in this axis by 0.
s equals 1 is the
critical frequency.
So we go up and
down 1 unit and we
draw the straight-line
approximation.
s equals 10 is the same
thing, except now it's
shifted to a higher frequency.
Factor of 10, units
shift on a log plot.
And now all we do is sum them,
add the first to the second,
add the third.
That's our angle approximation.
Again, the idea is
to take something
that's conceptually hard--
what's the value of
the angle function
as a function of frequency-- and
turn it into something simple.
A few straight line
segments associated
with every pole and zero.
So this is just a summary.
Because we can represent
a system that's
composed of integrators,
summers, and gains
by a linear
differential equation
with constant
coefficients, it follows
that the system function is a
quotient of polynomials in s.
Because of the fundamental
theorem in algebra,
there's n roots.
Because of factor theorem, you
can break it up into factors.
Because of all that, we can
think about them one at a time
and glue them together.
Gluing them together in
the case of the magnitude
works best if you use the log
because then the product turns
into a sum.
In the case of the
angle, it's for free
because the angle
is, in some sense,
already a logarithmic function.
OK.
OK, we'll see if you got it.
So here is a complicated
frequency response.
This is the straight-line
approximation to the frequency
response of a system.
Which system?
So which of the
system functions--
1, 2, 3, 4, or
none of the above--
is represented by the
Bode straight-line plot
showed above?
Raise your hands,
which one is better--
1, 2, 3, 4, or 5?
Ah, 100%.
That's exactly the right answer.
Wonderful.
The idea is that Bode is easy.
That's why we do it.
It's easy.
So tell me a rule.
How do I think about this one?
What would happen here?
What's this saying?
What would be the
Bode plot of this one?
Sketch it in the air.
Exactly.
You start at 0, right?
OK.
So start at 0.
Then what?
What do you run into first?
You start at 0.
What do you run into first
when you're doing this guy?
You run into this factor, or
that factor, or that factor
first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Yeah, the left one.
So think about the order.
By how close were
they to the origin?
Think about them in
order from the origin.
So you hit the first one
first, the one at 10,
then the one at 100.
This would start
flat, break down at 1,
break down again at 10,
break down again at 100.
That's not the right shape.
This one starts with a 0.
That's a break up.
The 0 happens at frequency 1.
So that's log frequency 0.
That's right.
Then, you break
down, break down.
OK.
So break up, break
up, break down.
Except that it would
actually break down first.
So the way to think
about this one
is break down,
break up, break up
ordered from going
away from the origin.
OK.
So the point is it's very
easy to take a system function
and immediately draw
the frequency response.
That lets you take a pole-zero
representation, which
can be very concise in terms
of the number of numbers
you need to know, and
quickly map out the frequency
response, which can be
very intuitive for thinking
about how the system responds.
OK.
So one more issue.
We don't really like log
plots when it gets down
to talking about the frequency
at which the log was 7.129.
We just don't like that because
nobody measures frequency
in the frequency whose log is x.
So what we usually do,
instead of plotting
versus the log of omega, we plot
versus omega on a log scale.
OK.
Very reasonable.
We just put tick marks and we
just label them exponentially.
So the tick mark associated
with omega is labeled 1, not 0.
That's frequency 1.
The tick mark associated with
frequency 10 is labeled 10.
What that means, though, is that
the growth inside that interval
is on a log scale.
That's why we write
log scale here
to keep reminding ourselves that
the ticks between 1 and 10--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5--
are not uniformly spaced.
They're log spaced.
The distance between 1 and 2
is bigger than the distance
between 9 and 10.
That's the way logs work.
OK.
So we think about frequency
on a log scale rather than
log frequency.
Similarly, we think about
amplitude on a dB scale
rather than log amplitude.
dB is for Alexander Graham Bell.
It's decibel.
A bell is a factor of 10.
It's a little unintuitive,
a factor of 10
is labeled 20, because Bell
was really thinking energy.
And you have to square energy.
You have to square
voltage to get energy.
Bell was thinking a
factor of 10 in energy.
We like to think amplitude.
Therefore, a factor of 10
for us would be 20 decibels.
20.
OK, so that's a little weird.
So we will think about
this axis in decibels
and we'll think about
that one in decades.
And so what that means
is that the slopes are
no longer minus 1 and 1.
The slopes are 20
decibels per decade,
or minus 20 decibels per decade.
Now, this is all
completely meaningless.
It's a slope of 1.
And you could equally have
labeled this axis in dB
and this axis on a log
scale, and then you
would have the slope
of 1 decade per 20 dB.
And that, too, would be 1.
We just don't do it that way.
OK.
What do we do?
What we do do is
frequency on a log scale.
So therefore, the unit of
frequency is the decade.
You have a frequency
and a decade
higher and a decade higher
and a decade higher.
The unit of frequency
is decade or octave.
Octave is a factor of 2.
Octave higher, factor of 2.
Octave higher.
Octave makes more sense if
you're a musician, right?
The distance between
two C's is an octave.
So that's a dB scale.
And that results in a
little bit of funny math.
So if you convert linear
measures of amplitude
to decibel measures, a
factor of 1 in amplitude
is a factor of 0 dB.
A factor of 10 is 20 dB.
We already talked about that.
There are some convenient
middle grounds.
2 is 6 dB.
That's a little weird.
So we'll go around saying
it's 6 dB and we mean 2.
But every engineer in the
world will call it 6 dB.
Half of that is the square
root of 2, which is 3 dB.
It's just convenient,
at least it
is after you spend
30 years doing that.
The other point
from the slide is
that the asymptotic responses
are really quite good.
The magnitude for a
single pole deviates
from the straight-line
approximation by only 3 dB.
I can hear sounds
that range 120 dB.
That's the sense in
which 3 is small.
The kinds of signals
we work with every day
have ranges that are
big compared to 3.
So we think of 3
as a small thing.
The phases are within 6 degrees.
And for a lot of applications,
6 degrees is a small number.
Again, we're thinking
6 out of 180.
So it's a small
fraction of a cycle.
OK, this is a good thing--
especially the fact that
it's a trick question--
for you to practice
for the exam.
So let me skip it in
the interest of time,
because there's one
more important thing.
Don't look at the answer.
Use this as practice.
There's one more
important thing in trying
to reduce poles and zeros
to a frequency response.
And that is that when you
use the fundamental theorem
of algebra, even though
the polynomial can
have real-valued coefficients,
that does not mean the roots
are real.
Right
The roots to a polynomial
with real value coefficients
can have complex parts.
So the remaining thing
I want to talk about
is, what do you do with these
poles that have complex parts?
The imaginary part has
to do with oscillations.
And so we want to think about,
what's a Bode plot looks like?
What's the asymptotes
look like when
you have a system like this?
This was a system that has
a mass spring, and dashpot.
You should have done
this by homework by now.
The differential
equation is second order.
It has real-valued coefficients,
but the holes are complex.
What happens with complex roots?
Well, if the com--
if the polynomial had
real-valued coefficients,
complex roots come in pairs.
That's the only way to
take a complex number
and end up with a
product that's all real.
You take the complex number.
It has to be paired with
its complex conjugate.
So that when you pair them, the
result has real coefficients.
So we only need to
worry about the case
when the poles or zeros
come in complex pairs.
And for that purpose, it's
convenient to think about--
you might think that if you
had mass-spring dashpot system,
you might be expecting
something like s
squared m plus sb plus
k, something like that.
Mass-spring and dashpot.
Three parameters.
Well, you don't
really need three.
Three is nice because it
has an association with how
stiff is this thing
and how massive
is that thing, et cetera.
But in terms of thinking
about poles and zeros,
you don't need to
think about all three.
First off, you could divide
the top and bottom by k
and the 1/k then is
just a gain factor.
Gains are easy.
They don't affect shape.
OK.
We don't care about that one.
So we went from 3 to 2.
Now, there's another
simplification
because all of these are
going to be oscillatory.
Pole pairs work in an
oscillatory fashion.
This has a natural frequency
that if I didn't shake it,
it has a preferred frequency.
If I divide by that
preferred frequency, omega 0,
I can get rid of
another parameter.
So don't think about s.
Think about s over omega 0.
Now, frequencies
are normalized to 1.
OK.
So by dividing by
omega 0, I turn
every frequency-dependent
system into something
whose best frequency
is near omega equals 1.
Then finally, for
my third parameter,
if I write my third
parameter as 1 over q,
something very magical
and wonderful happens.
The roots fall on a circle.
So what I want to show
here then is as I change q,
I don't need to
think about omega.
I can plot this on an
s over omega 0 plane
and it works for all omega.
I do need to worry about q.
So if I change q, here q is 1/2.
So there's q of 1/2.
1/4.
1/8.
Excuse me, I'm
doing it backwards.
I want 1/q to equal--
I want 1 over 2q to equal 1/2.
I need q equals 1.
OK, that's better.
That's q equals 1.
q equals 2 in order to half
the distance to the origin--
4, 8, 16.
Notice that as I change--
now watch this side.
So q equals 1.
So q equals 1, q equals 1.
Low-frequency magnitude is flat.
High-frequency is slope of 2.
Sloping down with minus 2.
As I change q from 1 to 2, 4,
8, 16, the peak gets bigger.
In fact, if you do a
little bit of math,
you can show that the
peak gets bigger with q.
The peak value, if
you measure how big
is the peak compared to
where is the crossover,
that distance is a factor of q.
Similarly-- and you
can reason about that
with vector diagrams.
And we'll do homework
problems to practice that.
Similarly, it got peakier.
It got sharper.
If you do the
vector story to try
to figure out why
it got peakier,
the width turns out to be 1/q.
So that's kind of impulse-y.
The height got bigger with q.
The width got bigger with 1/q.
The product always 1.
So that's a way of
thinking about why
it got peaky that way.
And finally, if you think about
the angle, the angle changes.
As you make q bigger and bigger,
the angle changes very quickly.
And it turns out that the
angle changes abruptly
over the same bandwidth.
Bandwidth is how many
frequencies are there
between the low-frequency part
and the high-frequency part.
The phase change over the
bandwidth is always pi over 2.
OK.
So that's the whole story then.
Think about isolating the
poles on the real axes.
They're just this.
Isolated zeros,
they're just this.
Pairs can be more complicated
because they can be peaky.
OK.
Thanks.